خط التماس بين الجيشين الروسي والاوكراني
لا يتحرك بشكل ملحوظ منذ سيطره روسيا على
ضخمه وبات واضحا ان الهجوم المضاد لا يسير
كما كان مخططا له بحسب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
رغم استمرار كييف باستهداف مناطق تسيطر
عليها روسيا ابرزها شبه جزيره القرم
المدينه التي تستضيف اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي اضافه الى ضرب مناطق في العمق
الروسي وهو تكتيك لوح به قائد الجيش
الاوكراني في حديث مع صحيفه واشنطن بوست
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز قالت ان الجيش
الاوكراني خسيرا نحو 20% من عتاده العسكري
خلال الاسبوعين الاولين من الهجوم المضاد
الذي بداه في الرابع من يونيو الماضي وان
الخسائر شملت معدات ودبابات ونقلات جند
مدرعه غربيه الصنع وتضيف الصحيفه ان حقول
الالغام هي العائق الاهم امام اي تقدم
اوكراني حيث عمد الجيش الروسي الى زرع
الغام مضاده للافراد والمدرعات بعمق
يتراوح بين خمسه و16 كيلومترا قرب معقله
الرئيسيه
الخسائر وضعت الجيش الاوكرانيه في موقف
دفاعي لاسيما على الجبهه الشرقيه بحسب
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
بينما قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ان جميع محاولات اوكرانيا اختراق الدفاعات
الروسيه خلال الهجوم المضاد باءت بالفشل
هذه العوامل دفعت القوات الاوكرانيه الى
تغيير تكتيكاتها للحد من خسائرها وركزت
على استخدام المدفعيه والصواريخ بعيده
المدى واعتماد مجموعات هجوميه تكتيكيه من
جنود المشاه بدلا من اللجوء الى توغل بري
واسع لتفادي الدخول في حقول الالغام
والاشتباك المباشر مع الجيش الروسي وضمن
التكتيكات الميدانيه تبرز اهميه القنابل
العنقوديه التي قد تكون اداه فعاله ضد
تقدم القوات الروسيه والاستهداف الخنادق
والتحصينات الروسيه بحسب ما كشفت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست نقلا عن الكنتاكون في وقت
تؤكد موسكو انها لم تلجا بعد الى ذخائر
العن لكنها تحتفظ بحقها في استخدامها متى
فعلت اوكرانيا بحسب الرئيس الروسي
لدى روسيا مخزون كاف من مختلف انواع
القنابل العنقوديه وحتى اللحظه لم نستخدمه
اذ لم تكن هناك ضروره لذلك ولكن اذا
استخدموها ضدنا فسنحتفظ بحق الرد بالمثل
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جاك سولفن
اعلن ان تزويد كييف بالذخائر العنقوديه
ياتي لتغطيه النقص في مخزونات ذخائر من
عيار
155 ملم
وبحسب سالب فان واشنطن اعطت ايضا الضوء
الاخضر للاوروبيين لبدء تدريب الاوكرانيين
على طائرات اف 16
فاوكرانيا ومنذ عده اشهر تطالب حلفاءها
بتزويدها بمقاتلات اف 16 لتغطيه النقص في
انظمه الدفاع الجوي وللايجاد بعض التوازن
في قدرات سلاح الجو الاوكراني مقارنه
بالقوه الجويه الروسيه
[موسيقى]